[Music]
Okay, it's me, Destin. I am here with Mike
Simons at the National Electronics Museum,
and he's going to show us something
that we interact with every day
that you probably didn't know.
So, what do you got for us, Mike?
(Mike) We have a microwave oven.
And the microwave is built on technology
that was developed during the Second
World war for radar equipment.
What we have here is just a standard,
off the shelf microwave oven
that we've modified.
You'll notice that you can't open up the
door and we've disabled the controls,
and it's got a separate
switch over here on the side.
What this is gonna show
is how the microwave beam travels
inside the cavity of the oven.
We've taken a sheet of plastic and we've
embedded Christmas bulbs into it,
and when I power this thing up it's gonna
spin, because it's on the carousel,
and as those bulbs flicker,
what that is is the beam
of microwave energy
that travels through the
inside of your oven.
[Click]
[Microwave hums]
Okay, so what you see here is that those...
the beam travelling through the bulbs.
The reason that you have a carousel
inside your microwave oven
is because that beam always
travels throught the same path.
It's just bouncing around inside of there.
So if you didn't have that carousel
if you put your cup of coffee in the center
of the oven it might not heat up correctly,
because that carousel
allows your cup of coffee
to travel through different
portions of that beam,
to make sure it heats up correctly.
This thing also has a heat sink in it,
to eliminate some of the heat
that's generated by those bulbs.
And we've also lowered the power on this,
But this is definately a
"do not try this at home".
But you can come to the National
Electronics Museum and check it out.
(Destin) Awesome. So what is the best way
to heat up my coffee in the morning?
- Uhm... probably a tea kettle on your stove.
[Destin laughs]
(Destin) Excellent.
So do you get more nerds, geeks
or dorks visiting you here,
at the National Electronics Museum?
- You know what, we've debated about what's
the difference between all three of those,
and you know what, I think we get all
three but I can't tell the difference.
(Destin) [Laughs] Excellent.
So if you get a chance,
come up to Baltimore
and go to the National Electronics Museum.
You'll learn something.
I now know to put my food
on the edge of the carousel
when I'm heating something up in
the microwave, is that correct?
(Mike) Not in the middle.
- That's right.
So come up and visit these geniuses
if you're a dork, geek, nerd,
or anybody that just wants to learn
more and be smarter every day.
Alright, thanks Mike.
- Yeah, thanks.
[Music]
...and where your relative motion is
going so you can compensate for it,
but chickens are really good at this so...
I'll show you. Watch his
head stay totally stationary
as I move his body...
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.